plusieurs mois déjà que les horodateurs
de fort-de-france ne fonctionne plus de
ce fait le stationnement au centre ville
n'est plus payant les automobilistes
s'en donnent à coeur joie
à peine libéré une place et rapidement
occuper parce que c'est très bien parce
que des fois on se donne n'importe
comment on a dépêché à chaque moment
c'est un peu chiant et les autres qu'on
me donne des contraventions sinon après
ça va je ne suis pas tellement pour il
faut qu'on paye parce qu'il faut quand
même la ville
avant ça c'est quand même l'économie
d'un fort de france qui prend un coup à
ce moment là cette gratuité du
stationnement au centre ville ne
bénéficient pas pour autant aux
commerçants les clients ne sont pas plus
nombreux pas du tout au contraire
puisque les clés les commerçants eux
mêmes les blast nos résultats les
clients qui viennent sur la ville
belle tournée en deux fois trois fois et
a présenté ses horodateurs qui
rapportait environ 400000 euros par an
la ville ne sont plus aux normes
c'est pour cela qu'ils seront remplacés
on peut pas dire qu'elle sera en panne
c'est simplement que la loi est venue
modifier le système
puisqu'on est passé au 1er janvier 2018
a service reliques de stationnement
payant sur voirie et par conséquent ses
horodateurs ne sont plus aux normes que
ce qu'évidemment le nouveau système doit
permettre de montrer la plaque
d'immatriculation du véhicule en
stationnement
d'ici septembre une nouvelle politique
de gestion du stationnement sera mise en
place à fort de france le chef lui
rentrera alors dans l'ère de la
modernité c'est effectivement la
possibilité d'utiliser des moyens
modernes de paiement
un des matières l'elysée notamment la
possibilité de télécharger sur son
smartphone une application qui permettra
de réserver son stationnement de payer
son stationnement à l'avance et si
effectivement on n'a pas payé en
dépassement de payer son forfait pro
stationnement de manière dématérialisée
vous avez encore quelques mois pour
profiter de la gratuité du stationnement
à fort de france
mais attention si vous
garez vous serez quand même verbaliser